[Music]
my strange addiction
eating sand i can't stop eating sane
but before this video begins let me tell
you guys about an upcoming live stream
this saturday
because i'm gonna play with you guys
through a new
awesome service called party what is
party
well usually in-game matchmaking sucks
let's get real here you end up with a
bunch of bozos
no one likes a bunch of bozos it also
takes long
it's unpredictable boo party makes
matchmaking safe
fun and rewarding yeah by helping you
find the perfect player to game with
maybe even gamer girlfriend wife
even better you like money you can get
money by hosting parties
and helping other gamers in a safe and
friendly environment
i'm talking ironically but it's
legitimately cool
join party with a link in the
description and use code pewdiepie
all caps all epic to subscribe and have
a chance to play with me
on live this saturday well probably
playing minecraft
so check that out use hashtag partygang
and i'll be able to find you as well
so party isn't about being the best
player necessarily it's not about how
many followers you have it's just about
connecting you with people
that you can vibe with basically there's
so many great gamers out there and
they want to hook you up with the right
gamers for you
and anyone has the opportunity to become
a partner and earn money on party which
is cool
so yeah subscribe to party link in the
description and i'll see you this
saturday
enjoy the video i can't stop eating sane
it just why why why i need to know this
my name is i'm 19 years old i'm 19.
i imagine like an old oh god [ __ ]
hey if you're 19 years old which i know
you are
and you're not eating sand hey at least
you know you're not doing that bad
oh god i feel so mean to eating sand oh
no
don't eat the same
how did that start oh i have so many
questions am i
first of all am i laughing at someone's
mental illness that is not the case
that my intention i'm fascinated oh bro
she you're just
chewing i love the crunch the crunch
it's always good on top of food like a
seasoning or something
all right sprinkle a little
insane over the hell yeah it does sam
doesn't taste anything i wouldn't know
because then
maybe that's the problem maybe we're
wrong and she's right
taking a tortilla chip dipped them in
tortilla chips are already crunchy
and they're not wet the sand is not
going to get applied to that that's a
terrible idea even from this logic of
eating sand to begin with that makes no
sense
[ __ ] am i the only one saying them and
they gave the
chick bro you can't dip but the tear in
sand that is not you're
[Music]
my favorite combination of sand is when
i mix it with gum
it's just like mouth watering
bria's addiction first developed five
years ago when she accidentally got a
mouth full of sand at the beach
that's so funny so if she if that never
happened she would never have been
addicted to sand just like one
day it could happen to all of us at any
point in our life
sand addiction it's real and it's out
there
and it's coming to get you this woman
has been eating
sand for years and she says she's never
felt better
she adopted her unusual diet in 1997
and says it's the only thing that's
cured her chronically upset stomach
i always imagine that that's the case
like it just happens randomly like
holy [ __ ] that tastes [ __ ] epic oh my
gosh
bro try some of this [ __ ] sand dude
when i'm walking to class
when i'm reading the book before i go to
bed i put like a pinch in my mouth
brea eats sand up to six times per day
is it weird that i'm starting to kind of
understand it like you
enjoy this texture in your mouth
throughout the day kind of like a gum
or something that's nearly
11 000 times since her addiction began
i mean yeah it is addiction i mean the
show is called my strange addiction i
understand that now but yeah
craving sand lick my finger and then
dip it inside of the sand and put it i
like how she has a different supply of
different stains the fact that it grits
on my teeth it gives it that
crunch that you don't get from food sign
is just like
it is it like what is sand you know that
that picture of microscopic sand that it
looks all amazing and you've seen that
right
i never questioned that i was wondering
if that was actually real or not like
hey look this is sand sand looks
unbelievably cool under a microscope
so it's just like seashells and like no
that can't be real
why do i not believe this this is
grinded
down like seashells and stuff i'm so
confused
what is sand i can't believe i'm asking
this
sand is a gran lose granule material
blanket yeah i know that but what is it
silicon dioxide in the form of quartz
yeah but is it safe
i mean it's natural wait there's there's
sand in food supplements
what i'm so confused anyway back to the
video maria is so dependent on that
satisfying crunch
she turns to nail files when her sand
supply runs low
it has like sandpaper on it that gives
me the same
i was not ready for that [ __ ] oh that is
pain i'm
i'm physically cringing don't eat
sandpaper
[Music]
i start by taking a handful
then i take like the big rocks out does
she
does does she have a cell or whatever
it's called in english like uh
so she filters it right at least you do
that
right right like if someone telling me
they were addicted to salmon was a
straight-up connoisseur and was like yes
this sign is
silicon oxide quartz from the beaches of
lambuth
it's one of the finest top 10 materials
and actually it exists
naturally in our bodies already so
there's really no
problem well you take sand as
supplements
i take it straight from the earth my
dude so we're just like going to a
[ __ ] playground and grabbing him
saying that's nasty
if she ever becomes homeless you'll
never be hungry
you can't lie we've all had centered on
laughs before yeah but no one likes
it it's of course rough irritating
and it gets everywhere i hate saying
yeah i hate saying
i want to know how her teeth are like
she's eating like this guy they got to
be like
grind it down right you live one life
and you're living it
wait what is this addicted to bee stings
no
no my name is margaret and i'm 53 years
old
i live in morning view kentucky and i'm
addicted to stinging myself with bees
oh god i'm cringing myself on my hip my
elbow on a finger
my ankle my forehead doesn't that kill
the bee though you're
you're b killer i really love stinging
myself with bees
explain explain elaborate i want every
detail
until i'm convinced and if i'm not
convinced i'm just gonna say you're
crazy which is nothing wrong with being
crazy
of course of course isn't it important
that we're keeping the bee population
live this woman is destroying the earth
margaret has been addicted to bee stings
for the past 10 years
she looks so surgical with it her
addiction
as a way to relieve her arthritis in
search
it relieves arthritis b venom seemed to
prevent
arthritis with the help of hormones
called glucorticoids
these hormones help regulate
inflammation inflammation
really so there's a magic medical reason
behind it
oh okay well don't i feel silly now
is there no other way to get this glue
core decoyed
steroid hormones [ __ ] margaret turned to
the beehives in her backyard
oh my god the face to relieve
certain pain symptoms the first time
that i stung
myself it didn't hurt as bad as i
thought it would and
it just got easier every time oh my god
but what started as an occasional prick
of pain for medical reasons
has spiraled into 15 stings a day 15.
trigger points right here that i like to
sting kind of put a little dent in it
with my
fingernail i gently tap even the dog is
judging her jesus
and it comes away like that
oh don't make that face she's always had
kind of a taste for
looking at the odd side of things
at this point now with 15 stings a day
that's when i'm starting to get really
concerned about this
15 stings a day 54
750 bees killed by this woman
someone did the math f's in the chat for
all the fallen beasts my
gosh my name is natasha
i'm 40 years old alright what's wrong
with you natasha
she eats cactus and i'm addicted to
eating clay masks
oh the sand it's it's weird how the sand
is starting to make sense at least i'm
seeing this
it tastes wonderful like
wet rocks always comfortable
it makes me want to die dude [ __ ] stop
and savor that flavor of my earthiness i
can't wash this [ __ ] man
natasha has been addicted to eating clay
face masks
stop making that face she's so hooked
that she consumes up to a jar a day
a jar a day my dude
how many calories are in there i eat it
starts off in a
very fine powder sort of like
when you get sand in your mouth what is
with sand
what is with sand people stop
yeah i thought it was a joke at first
like i mean come on now you eat what
[Music]
look at her she has it all over her wait
that's a different story you said one
but natasha doesn't just eat the face
mask straight out of the jar she also
dips chips in it
and even relax what is with dipping
chips and it makes no sense
a step has to be moist
otherwise what's the point every evening
with clay mask
and a beer it tastes like wet rocks how
is that tasty
how is that tasty explain yourself now
despite the mess natasha is so dependent
on her face mask
she won't leave home without a stash you
never know when you need a little dip
you know
i don't know i'm also bothered by the
fact that she's spelling it everywhere
like okay if you wanna
i don't know you know what not okay but
still you don't have to spill it out
like a peg i have taken at work work
they just shake their head and just make
me feel so
strange because it is
natasha turned to clay face masks seven
years ago
to satisfy a taste for rocks what
what is with rocks and taste no one's
ever looked at a rock and said i want to
taste that
no one stupid i had a girlfriend who
said that she had
cravings like that she says put a little
this on your tongue and so
i tried it and it was like what have we
learned here today
just be [ __ ] crazy that's what we
god damn her teeth are hella white
though does that have anything to do
with the vase again
you know i mean this might be our secret
for to look young
maybe we're the wrong ones right uh it's
another crazy woman guys how about that
i'm 43 mom of two beautiful children
and i'm addicted to drinking paint as
stop it you shame yourself
you foul demon enough
it's going down your throat it feels
very nice and warm almost like a
thicker version of warm milk then drink
a thick ass milk [ __ ] drink milk
[ __ ]
but obviously it's got that very strong
chemical taste to it
i enjoy how it kills my brain cells
which is perfect
no difference from alcohol really
it's perfect for me
hey heather let me hook you up with a g
fuel shake it tastes
amazing check out link in the
description markzter designed these
flora gang
cups i can hook you up for free just if
you stop drinking the paint
three gallons of paint when you get the
marker you need to shake it up obviously
it's like your standard
obviously obviously you need to shake it
up you [ __ ] fools
you can already see that there is some
white paint around the edge
so i'll put that into my mouth and suck
the excess off take that off
and now you have
[Music]
i can't do this what i drink
obviously it's not something that i can
do in front of my children
so that's why i don't tell anybody on my
teeth or on my mouth or spelled it on my
breath
but no one no one knows that i drink
paint
it's your secret how you well kept well
done
no one's gonna find out ever oh [ __ ]
[Applause]
paint often contains more than half a
dozen lethal chemicals including xylene
oh how about that so maybe stop
stephanie and i are best friends
today i'm going to admit my addiction to
drinking paint to stephanie
i brought you here because i want to
tell you something because
it's something she's going to be like
bargaining with her like
listen i know it sounds crazy but just
like try it bro
try it and then tell me what you feel
about it
you can't don't knock it unless you try
it my dude i
am addicted to drinking paint well she
knows she's addicted
that's the first step paint out of paint
markers
yeah wow been doing it for
about two two and a half years really
so how much are you drinking a day an
hour um
a week a marker a day sometimes more
really have you thought of what this is
going to do to your children
what you have done to your body i have
my kids are the main reason for
doing this i'm always here no matter
what i know
oh the intervention thing okay good good
she recognizes that i don't not at all
that's all right all right sorry now i
feel bad for shaming you know we need to
support people with addiction
to help them get out of it but also
what the [ __ ] dude if i thought of you i
know
so i got your lab results back and
your kidney function is a little bit
abnormal
that's it that's it i thought she'd be
rottening inside
a little bit abnormal paint in the lungs
can cause
pulmonary hemorrhage and can cause death
well i'm ready i'm ready to do this
because i will quit
okay i'm good i will listen to her no
doubt
that's brave of you heather well done
well done
ah excellent all right that was a nice
ending to this story
well done heather oh my god you're
steamers so what was the secret
girl all right that was pain that was
pure pain but we got through it if you
enjoyed
hit that like and subscribe support
channel get g
fuel and i'll see you tomorrow